oh my gosh you guys look damn cornhole  we have to play just the best game ever  come on in  hey what's up how are you game having a  fight with my sister right now it's oh  my god in the traffic get in here this  morning was too much do you experience  that how are you I'm good do you've any  ranch do we have any ranch oh excuse me  can I get us at a ranch all right so  we're almost to the expressway  I mean the freeway oh you don't wish to  do this weekend what we should go to the  lake you mean the beach no my friend is  a boat Oh totally go to the lake  and do what just hang out  [Music]  I need to use the restroom do you want  me to order you anything if the waitress  comes out of the pot what oh oh oh are  you ready to go  oh yeah No  what is that puppy chow try some okay  that's very good I'll take that thank  you hi hey how are you hi  [Applause]  [Music]